we're thrilled to have on the
representative of the Atlanta Hawks and
last night's NBA draft lottery who whose
presents lit up Twitter there's no other
way to describe a Jami Gertz here on the
rich Ison show how are you Jamie I'm
great rich thank you for having me how
are you I am doing fine for all of your
shocked fans out there how did you wind
up where you were last night how did I
wind up it's such a long story but um
this is our fourth season we're going
into our port season of owning the
Atlanta Hawks basketball team my husband
Tony wrestler and myself along with our
ownership group Grant Hill and Sara
Blakely we we were kind of kicking the
tires on the Clippers a while ago and
then that went for tons of dough and
grant called us and said the Atlanta
Hawks are for sale and I said haha
never saw myself in Atlanta but that
sounds like something that might be
interesting and it was an auction and it
kind of happened within four days and we
became the new ownership of the Atlanta
Hawks basketball team okay without a lot
of fanfare so I don't think many people
knew that correct
you know they know me as Jamie grits the
actress so it wasn't a lot of you know
discussing basketball for the last four
years but last night was kind of my
coming-out party easy very much so so
how did you prepare for last night's
roll then Jamie do you know what
I literally just kind of my husband said
to me you brought me a lot of luck for
the past thirty years so I was like you
could be the one to help pick us our
lottery pick and I was like are you
serious honey I can't believe that
you're making me do this but I have to
say it was tons of fun I think ignorance
is bliss so I kind of did you know I was
the one up there who really you know I
know it was important to us and I knew
what our percentage
as I think it was 13.7% chance and so
you know the train left the station and
you just jump on board and I was just
decided that I was going to have a good
time okay so Jami Gertz you are saying
that you knew going in that your chances
were not less than zero so what you're
saying they were not less than zero I
feel my odds were a little better than
that for sure
you do realize that there were just tons
of your I guess your your filmography
and TV references being made on on
Twitter last night are you aware I my I
have three sons
Oliver Nick & Co and they seem to be
texting me that that things were being
said I'm you know not the best social
media girl so they they were proud they
thought it was pretty cool so if it made
me cool in my children's eyes I've I've
done my job well mom was trending last
night Jamie mom was trending so you know
there's a few there are a few spare
square tweets on Twitter than when I'm
in the restroom and someone asked me
[Laughter]
like hey can you spare square I'm like
no you're not have a square root of
stairs okay all right so in all in all
how do the Hawks as an organization feel
about that third overall selection that
you were able to bring home I think the
fact that we moved up was huge I mean I
was just looking at my husband and my
son and Travis flanked our GM and they
were so they were beaming you know we
did a little rehearsal they do a little
rehearsal with everyone and they said
okay if you become the top three then
there are these marks you have to go
stand on and I'm like oh well I've been
doing after 35 years you're just
preaching to the choir I know how to hit
my mark so once I knew that we were you
know top three and I saw the relief in
their face you know I knew that I had
had done my job and the real work starts
now for them and figuring out
best pieces of the puzzle for the
Atlanta Hawks going forward and it's
just so exciting for us I think I think
you know we inherited a lot when you buy
a team especially when it goes so
quickly and you come in there we were
new to the city and you have to really
be delicate and listen a lot and learn a
lot and then eventually you have to make
it your own those decisions and those
choices have to become your own and now
with Travis being our new GM and with
Boyd Pearce being our new coach who we
just hired this week you know we're on
our way we're putting the pieces of that
puzzle together and it's very exciting
for our fans and all of Atlanta well I
really do of our arena we just broke
ground on our G league and we have a
brand new state-of-the-art practice
facility so I guess I'll see it next
year Super Bowl is that where the next
time I'll see you in this morning event
because that's in Atlanta I don't see
you you better believe it you know mr.
blank is so kind to us and it's it's
really the small kind of community the
sports community in Atlanta between the
Braves the Falcons in the Hawks
so you will absolutely see me at the
Super Bowl I did
I wasn't Houston when the Falcons lost
which was my first Super Bowl ever and I
openly wept it my first Super Bowl cuz I
was so sad so you you could say that by
the end of the game the Falcons were the
Lost Boys so you're saying you saw Dana
Delany tweeted last night to the actress
that she saw you trending and then was
relieved to see it was for good news
she's been found in my hotel room and
without a square to spare Jamie was
great seeing you in that role last night
and that and obviously in that position
and and for all your fans to see you
with a with a whole new world at your
fingertips so congrats on that move
we'll check down the line I look forward
to it rich thank for him thank you for
having me on I appreciate it and go hawk
you got
there god this Jami Gertz everybody the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience